bonsoir à tous ravis vous retrouver sur
lcp au menu ce soir un savon garde
spéciale législatives à 48 heures du
premier tour de ce scrutin on fait le
bilan de cette campagne avec nos invités
les questions ne manquent pas emmanuel
macron aura-t-il une majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale n'a t-il pas
démarré sa campagne un peu trop tard
jusqu'où peut aller l'alliance porté par
jean luc mélenchon alias la tortue
s'agace c'est comme cela qu'ils se
surnomme lui-même c'est la victoire est
vraiment à portée de main pour lui et le
rn dans tout cela marine le pen est
longtemps resté en retrait de cette
campagne ne s'est elle pas fait voler la
place de première opposante à emmanuel
macron enfin la droite peut-elle créer
la surprise comme l'espère christian
jacob on en débat dans un instant avec
nos invités voilà pour le sommaire
installez vous confortablement chez vous
c'est parti pour une heure d'infos et de
débats
[Musique]
je veux alerter aussi les françaises et
les français sur l'importance du choix
qu'ils ont devant eux dès le 12 juin
prochain
si l'élection du président de la
république est cruciale
l'élection des députés est décisive le
chef de l'état obligé donc d'intervenir
en fin de campagne pour remettre un peu
d'enjeu dans ce scrutin est surtout pour
mobiliser son propre camp son propre
électorat est ce que cela sera suffisant
pour lui offrir une majorité absolue à
l'assemblée on en débat avec nos invités
pascal perrineau bonsoir vous êtes
politologue professeur à sciences po
paris bruno cautrès bonsoir politologue
également chercheur au cnrs et membre du
cevipof catherine tricot bonsoir
directrice de la revue regards qui se
définit à la fois comme une revue
indépendante et engagée engagé à gauche
je lui laisse israël à gauche voilà et
puis étienne girard qui est rédacteur en
chef à l'express à nous rejoindre dans
un instant mais d'abord pour ceux qui
sont passé un peu à côté de cette
campagne des législatives
stéphane blakowski nous offre une
session de rattrapage
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane bon sens clément un
bonsoir à toutes et à tous alors si j'ai
bien compris stéphane et ben si j'ai
bien compris clément la campagne des
législatives
elle a commencé alors que la
présidentielle n'était même pas terminé
souvenez vous c'était pendant
l'entre-deux-tours donc jean luc
mélenchon des dettes battu pour la
troisième fois de suite à la
présidentielle d'ailleurs le soir de sa
défaite il avait laissé entendre que le
temps était peut être venu de laisser la
place aux jeunes donc le 19 avril quand
bruce toussaint interdit mélenchon voilà
certains calvi retraités on va peut-être
faire le bilan de sa carrière peut-être
même qu'on va verser une larme on sait
pas surprise non seulement vous devez
séchez vos larmes mais la loi de la vie
c'est que c'est la vie qui est la plus
forte et dans la vie c'est le combat qui
est le plus fort si bien que je suis
venu ce soir vous dire une chose je
demande aux français de m'élire premier
ministre
je leur demande pour mes lire premier
ministre délire une majorité de députés
insoumis
insoumis et union populaire
alors c'est moi que les inscrits sont
quand même une très bonne équipe de
campagne un jour nous présente les gens
qui sont derrière tout ça parce que
bella la réélection de macron on avait
effectivement sur tout les murs des
grandes villes à paraître cette fameuse
affiche avec ce fameux slogan mélenchon
premier ministre et au départ et bien
ses adversaires n'ont pas forcément pris
au sérieux 1 on est parent a dit par un
monsieur mélenchon qui n'est réalisé un
peu les institutions soient bien qu'en
france le premier ministre n'est pas élu
par les français il est désigné par le
président de la république donc ce que
vous nous raconter c'est impossible mais
maintenant on sait que impossible n'est
pas mélenchon la preuve regardez l'union
de la gauche voilà un truc complètement
impossible ça on était sûr qu'il
n'arriverait jamais à s'entendre surtout
après la campagne où ils se sont plaints
gay dans tous les sens ça paraissait
inconcevable et pourtant mélenchon l'a
fait alors faut dire qu'avec le score
des dalles go à la présidentielle
quelqu'un s'en souvient
1,78
il ya pas mal de jeunes socialistes que
qui ont trouvé que c'était beau mourir
pour ses idées tapez 1 pour la social
démocratie mais non la finir au
cimetière des éléphants n'ont
certainement pas on écoute
il s'agirait jouvet mais son prénom âge
là vos billets c'est pierre qui a fait
dans ce pays que la gauche qui étaient
aux responsabilité qui avait tous les
pouvoirs s'est retrouvé écroulé c'est
quand même pas la responsabilité de ma
génération de ces femmes et de ces
hommes que vous citiez tout à l'heure
donc à un moment moi je dis à ces
éléphants laissez-nous faire laissez
nous tranquilles vous avez saborder le
parti socialiste quand il était au plus
haut niveau maintenant laissez nous
allons chez top quoi oui mais ça suffit
pour l'instant vous nous avez parlé que
de jean luc mélenchon avec lui dans
cette campagne quand même
tout le monde va parler que d'eux jean
luc mélenchon et même nous on en est
réduit à ça on regarde et il y avait des
articles dans le parisien sur le temps
de parole en fête sur le mois de mai
mélenchon et ses alliés bien sûr ont
occupé plus de la moitié du temps de
parole dans les médias parfois même
beaucoup plus donc il faut dire que en
même temps il se passait pas grand chose
en comme accro alors ici il ya la
république en marche et qui a changé de
nom est ce que vous connaissez le
nouveau nom de la république en marche
petit est
renouvelée sans et bien
si vous voyez l'efficacité du changement
de nom de la république en marche
surpris il a fallu se mettent d'accord
sur les investitures avec des forts
tempéraments françois bayrou et edouard
philippe donc on se souvient de la photo
on sentait qu'ils avaient passé une
bonne journée ensemble est vraiment bien
entendu
donc et puis après tout des illusions je
te l'avais noté la promesse de sarkozy
qui avait dit blanc attend dé moi je
vais vous ramenez 60 députés aient l'air
donc quand macron ça va pas traîner bon
en fait christian jacob comme on dit
chez les paysans c'est à la fin de la
foire qu'on compte les bouses et
finalement il ya eu tant de départ que
ça on écoute on nous avait annoncé il ya
trois semaines un mois une cinquantaine
après on est passé à une trentaine après
une dizaine maintenant nous dit entre 5
et 7 et là où il y en a 1 effectivement
peut-être y en aura deux de tulle nous
rentrons
bon il ya quand même mieux le ralliement
de damien abad pas gentil de se moquer
clément parce que c'est bien que le
ralliement de cadre à bad c'était
justement le mien bat damien pardon
n'est pour rien dans cette histoire vous
accusez de rien en revanche damien abad
livre ces accusations d'agression
sexuelle ça évidemment tomber un peu
plus le camp de mâcon ce terme on a
l'impression de fait au lieu de mener la
campagne le corps macron a subi cette
campagne au lieu de défendre leur idée
de proposer quelque chose ils ont passé
leur temps à se défendre contre hausse
de toutes les polémiques donc damien bat
bien sûr après ce qu'on appelle le
fiasco du stade de france la même marine
le pen qu'on avait quasiment pas entendu
dans cette campagne qui n'était que
préoccupé de de sortir zemmour du jeu
balla avec le stade de france bien sûr
on ouvrait la voie pour ressent couple
ait préféré c'est gravissime les faits
sont gravissimes et le mensonge du
ministre est gravissime en réalité la
france a donné le spectacle de ce
qu'elle est en train de devenir c'est à
dire une zone de non-droit général et ce
sous la pression d'une immigration
anarchique et d'une délinquance qui est
hors contrôle emmanuel macron dans tout
cela ah bah vous citiez le lièvre et la
tortue il ya un moment à un verre qui
dit il croyait qu'ils croient qu'il y
allait de son honneur de partir tard par
un du yen donc il y allait peut-être de
son honneur de partir par à mâcon 2 2
dire enfin quand même on va me faire
confiance m'a pas tant que ça donc il
est parti très tard mais donc il a dû
aller à fond donc pas le temps de faire
dans la finesse l'argument massue c'est
écoutez si vous votez pas pour moi ça
sera le désordre et de toute façon
mélenchon le pen tout ça c'est les
populistes on les met dans le même sac
on écoute il faudrait préférer où
l'affrontement en classe contre classe
ou religion contre religion ou l'origine
contre origine alors que la force de
notre pays c'est celle de la république
citoyenne citoyens avec des différences
d'origine de classe de philosophie
certains qui croient et d'autres qui ne
croient pas mais des droits et des
devoirs à tenir et un commun qui nous
lie alors moi je trouve que c'était un
beau disque hausse était bien envoyé est
ce que ça sera suffisant pour arriver en
tête au premier tour là il ya débat
merci beaucoup stéphane blakowski on
vient d'avoir un brillant résumé de
cette campagne des législatives avant de
commencer à en débattre j'aimerais avoir
votre ressenti personnel à tous les
trois si vous deviez retenir trois halls
et b pour qualifier cette cette campagne
pascal perrineau on commence par vous
écouter il n'existe et ça d'abord second
terme
le premier aussi comme comme impression
ce qui est très étonnant dès qu'on
voyait dans les statistiques projetées
tout à l'heure c'est une campagne qui
part sur de mauvaises informations c'est
à dire en particulier l'idée qu'il y ait
une dynamique irrésistible delà du ps
c'est faux si vous faites le total des
candidats qui représente les forces qui
constitue la nuit baisse au 1er tour de
l'élection présidentielle ça fait trente
et 1,6 pour cent des suffrages exprimés
la nuit baisse aujourd'hui encore dans
les derniers sondages les meilleurs est
annoncée à 27,5 c'est à dire quatre
points derrière il n'ya pas
objectivement et subjectivement c'est
tout à fait autre chose il n'ya pas
objectivement de dynamique de la nuque
mais cela nous pèse a perdu par rapport
à son stock électorale de la
présidentielle la présidentielle et sur
le début de la campagne des législatives
par rapport aux 26 il a élu une
croisière coup de magicien coup de
magiciens de mélenchon où ça arrive et
il est très fort il a fait croire à
quelque chose qui n'existe pas c'est ce
qu'on appelle aussi en sociologie est un
terme très amusant c'est la prophétie
autorisation n'est auto coeur d'une
prophétie auto réalisatrice qui peut
être va se réaliser je ne crois pas
personnellement que la duchesse est
capable de gagner ces élections mais
capable de pertus de perturber assez
profondément le jeu bruno cautrès trois
adjectifs pour qualifier cette campagne
atone pas de tonalité
étrange très étrange c'est même une
certaine manière puisque on voit que
dans un premier temps il y à un
événement important qui se passe qu'est
la création de la nuque ps
étrange aussi la disparition presque du
chef de l'état à un moment donné absorbé
par la nomination de la première
ministre et du et du gouvernement mais
qui tarde à afficher au fond fortement
son implication son engagement dans la
campagne et 3e qualificatif surprenant
de manière surprenante gérer prometteuse
prometteuse pourquoi on est heureuses
parce que ces élections législatives
envoie un rôle tout à fait capital dans
ce qui va se dérouler dans les cinq ans
du mandat des manuels macron et
plusieurs forces politiques sont en
train de jouer leur survie lors leur
croisée des chemins avec potentiellement
beaucoup de choses qui peuvent en
découler selon les résultats des
législatives j'en prendrais un seul un
seul exemple si malgré les réserves qui
vient d'exprimer pascal perri dans la
nuit ps montre aux différentes
composantes de la nuque pardon que ça
valait le coup c'est à dire qu'il ya
plus de députés à l'issue de cette
coalition qu'il y en aurait eu sinon
vous qu'il n'y en avait en 2017 les
acteurs de cette coalition vont dire
mais en fait ça marche et donc ça peut
changer quelque chose ça n'est qu'un
exemple de ses dimensions
potentiellement prometteuse
de cette campagne de cette drôle et
l'étrange de campagne étienne girard qui
nous a rejoint bonsoir rédacteur en chef
à l'express comment vous qualifiez vous
cette campagne des législatives
du côté de jean luc mélenchon astucieuse
puisqu'il a réussi à transformer une
troisième place à la présidentielle en
alternative aux élections législatives
au point aujourd'hui d'apparaître comme
un candidat crédible à matignon ce qui
si on rembobine le film apparaît tout à
fait étonnant du côté des manuels macron
raté il faut bien le dire tout s'est mal
embouché depuis le début depuis le
lendemain de sa réélection c'était le
maître des horloges aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que c'est un peu le lapin
blanc d'alice au pays des merveilles il
essaye de rattraper le temps perdu et de
relancer la campagne au dernier moment
la polémique damien abad ce qui s'est
passé au stade de france ce qui s'est
passé autour d'élisabeth bornes avec
cette dame handicapée cet échange où
elle a pu apparaître comme peu
empathique bref voit les tuiles se sont
amoncelées autour de la république en
marche et puis plus globalement cette
campagne elle a été avant tout confuse
or je suis d'accord avec mes camarades
ya pas eu de campagne c'est à dire sur
le fond voulait dire sur les sur les
thèmes de fond qu'elle est quel thème
est ressortie autour de cette campagne
aucun il n'y a eu aucun thème on a
peut-être un as au tout dernier moment
fait la police où l'on comprend vraiment
bien les lignes de partage et une vision
de la société au pouvoir d'achat quand
même tout à fait différent le pouvoir
d'achat alors oui parce que c'est un
temps on sent une inquiétude et une
demande extrêmement fortes de la
population est ce qu'au niveau des
propositions on a vu des choses
nouvelles à paraître depuis l'élection
présidentielle ça me convainc beaucoup
moins le gouvernement finalement a
expliqué qu'il gouvernait et qu'il
prenait une série de mesures mais sans
sans package de mesures qui change
totalement la donne sur ces questions là
catherine frécaut de votre côté très
inattendu le retour de la gauche c'est à
dire que ce n'est pas 5 me croyez pas
vous la mode au début c'est donc jusqu'à
présent il y avait jean luc mélenchon
d'un côté donc la france a soumis ce qui
constitue une partie de la gauche mais
enfin certainement pas toute la gauche
et puis un parti socialiste encalminé
dans son passé qui faisait qu'il n'avait
plus de voix qui ne se faisait plus
entendre du reste de l'électorat de
gauche ont fait donc on avait une une
gauche qui était hémiplégique enfin qui
lui manquait vraiment une partie en plus
la contre-performance des écologistes et
puis la très faible très faible résultat
de russel ça faisait kébé le au soir du
premier tour de la présidentielle on
n'avait que la fille et puis d'un seul
coup on se retrouve on se retrouve avec
une gauche qui redevient composite est
réuni ce qui était attendu par les
électeurs de gauche je pense qu'on va le
voir dimanche par ces terres que les
dissidents mon ferme à mon sens de
faibles résultats et que les électeurs
les candidats qui vont avoir
l'investiture nuque vont faire bon pour
faire le plein à mon avis des électeurs
de gauche et dont il ya le retour de la
gauche qui avait disparu même jean-luc
mélenchon d'employer plus jamais le
terme de gauche c'était devenu un gros
mot de dire la gauche et là d'un seul
coup ben voilà il ya ce alors
l'hypothèse l'art devient et puis ce que
j'allais dire je le dirai comme vous
c'est que c'est une élection qui a
repris 2 du sens parce qu'on sent
qu'elle va déterminer la suite de
l'histoire dira que les a le rapport de
force qui va se cristallisent
politologues ou journalistes vous sentez
qu'il ya de l'enjeu qu'elle est
importante cette élection mais avant de
dérouler les stratégies des uns et des
autres que vous avez déjà évoqué
j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête quand même sur
ce qui s'annonce comme un taux
d'abstention historique 1 et on sait que
l'abstention où la participation ça va
être la clé de ce scrutin le dernier
sondage ipsos évoque 46 % de
participation des français ce serait du
jamais vue lors d'une élection
législative
bruno cautrès vous êtes penché sur cette
question dans une étude je crois avec la
fondation jean jaurès qui a été détaillé
par le journal le monde hier comment
est-ce que vous expliquer ce désintérêt
de beaucoup de français pour cette
élection qui commence c'est tous va
déterminer beaucoup de choses pour les
cinq ans à venir
en dehors de tous les éléments qu'on
vient de convient de rappeler
l'étrangeté de la campagne du
comportement de campagne de l'exécutif
on pourrait dire il ya des dimensions
beaucoup plus structurelle on voit
depuis 2002 c'était au fond depuis lé
quinquennat il ya aux élections
législatives - de participation cause et
l'excellent qu'à l'élection
présidentielle qui était simplement
quelques semaines avant et ça s'est
accentué en particules en 2017 ou
l'abstention est devenue majoritaire au
2e tour des législatives avec un très
fort décrochage par rapport à la à la
présidentielle on voit qu'il ya une
dimension de cette élection que notre
collègue gérard grumberg avait appelé
l'élection à 4 tours où de plus en plus
les législatives sont perçus comme la
simple on va dire le lendemain ou le
surlendemain de l'élection
présidentielle les français ont beaucoup
de mal à identifier de quoi il s'agit
pourquoi il faut revenir aux urnes
quelques semaines après alors que la
grande élection entre guy m'a déjà a
déjà lieu donc beaucoup de difficultés
pour identifier
l'absence de campagne n'a pas n'a pas
aidé bien évidemment et on s'est toutes
les études le montrent que dès lors que
vous avez beaucoup de tours d'élections
qui ont lieu dans un laps de temps qui
est qu'est couilles et une fatigue des
électeurs qui disent qu'ils s'installent
et beaucoup d'électorat sont passés à
autre chose
déjà en jambes eux-mêmes déjà ces
élections législatives dont voilà une
tendance un peu inquiétant parce qu'il
s'agit quand même on est bien placés ici
pour en parler il s'agit d'élire le
législateur ce qui en démocratie
électorale n'est pas une petite affaire
pascal perrineau on parle d'un concept
l'abstention différentiel en fait ça
consiste à savoir la capacité de chaque
camp à mobiliser ses électeurs et quand
on regarde un peu ce qu'il en est en
s'appuyant sur le vote du premier tour
de la présidentielle on se rend compte
que ce sont les électeurs des lib dém
anyama crew qui sont aujourd'hui à
l'heure qu'il est les plus motivés pour
aller voter 56% d'entre eux quand elle
est votée il ya ensuite l'électorat de
balle et valérie pécresse celui de jean
luc mélenchon est assez loin derrière
celui de marine le pen
et pourtant aujourd'hui on voit que
cette alliance des gauches grignote
petit à petit son retard sur la majorité
présidentielle et même fini par passer
devant en intentions de vote là encore
c'est le sondage ipsos publié hier qui
montre que la nuque baisse ou la nuque
et est crédité de 28% d'intentions de
vote contre 27% pour ensemble comment
vous expliquer ce qui peut paraître
comme un paradoxe
alors simulé l'abstention seul but à
plusieurs logiques qui a bien sûr une
dimension de l'abstention qui est majeur
aujourd'hui c'est l'abstention politique
l'abstention est utilisée comme moyen de
protestation contre la politique en
général système politique la classe
politique et faut pas croire aujourd'hui
en france il n'y a pas de désir clair
d'une majorité ou d'une autre ni de la
majorité ni une ni deux la majorité
ensemble ni d'une autre majorité il n'y
a pas de désir d'une majorité forte et
il ya une autre dimension dans
l'abstention c'est l'abstention à
dimension démographique et sociale on
sait que les jeunes en particulier les
moins de 30 ans s'abstiennent beaucoup
plus que les autres tranches d'âge et on
sait aussi que les couches populaires
ouvriers et employés s'abstiennent
sensiblement plus que les couches
moyennes et que ce qu'on pourrait
appeler la bourgeoisie la bourgeoisie
intellectuelle de haut niveau de diplôme
etc or ça n'est pas du tout étonnant que
l'électorat macro et que l'électorat
pécresse soit les électeurs puisque ce
sont les électorats les plus âgées allez
les scores fait par madame pécresse mais
surtout par emmanuel macron chez les
plus de 65 ans sont des score
extrêmement élevé et ça devrait se
traduire en intentions de vote par
rapport aux autres forces politiques non
et oui mais vous avez simplement on est
dans l'abstention comme vous les
différentiels tout le monde est touché
mais plus ou moins alors qu'ils aient
touché le plus bien sûr c'est
l'électorat de marine le pen parce que
l'électorat qui a fait
score tout à fait important chez les
jeunes faut faire très attention quand
on parle des jeunes et deux
du leader de la nuque jean luc mélenchon
ce sont des jeunes particulier les
jeunes de milieux populaires ils ont
voté avant tout rassemblement national
et marine le pen donc quand on est jeune
et milieux populaires la probabilité
d'aller de ne pas se rendre aux urnes
pour les législatives est extrêmement
élevé donc les candidats du fn vont
souffrir ils vont souffrir dimanche il
n'y a pas de mobilisation et on le voit
d'ailleurs dans les projections des dés
aujourd'hui est d'une certaine manière
la majorité actuelle et par sa
sociologie et sa démographie
relativement avantage est très bien on
va voir on va se pencher sur les
stratégies déployées en maintenant par
les uns et les autres dans cette
campagne on commence par la majorité
sortante par emmanuel macron est
ensemble à peine élu on a eu le
sentiment qu emmanuel macron a voulu
mettre les deux pieds sur le frein d'un
coup pour anesthésier la campagne c'est
l'expression qui a été reprise par par
son entourage son idée c'était un peu de
laisser jean luc mélenchon s'épuiser en
quelque sorte boxer dans le vide et
c'était aussi d'éviter les erreurs les
boulettes qu aurait pu promettre le
nouveau gouvernement comme on l'avait vu
avec notamment la tva sociale et jean
louis borloo au début son entourage a
parlé d'un coup de génie étienne girard
est ce que vous reprendriez ce terme
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron a effectué
un coup de gilles oui c'est comme ça que
c'est comme ça que s'étaient présentés
non je considère pas vraiment été une
erreur oui pour moi le l'erreur
originelle cc 26 jours au début de son
mandat ont très bien d'avoir un
gouvernement entre sa réélection et la
nomination d'elizabeth borrel deux jours
pour les avais de bonnes 26 pour le
gouvernement vous avez raison 20 voilà
ce c'est plus de trois semaines entre sa
réélection et la nomination du
gouvernement pourquoi parce que la tante
créer un effet d'attentes on se demande
pendant trois semaines que nous réserve
emmanuel macron qui nous a habitués à
des surprises considérable edouard
philippe il y a cinq ans sa nomination
c'était pour le coup alors je sais pas
s'il faut parler de coup de génie mais
c'était un coup stratégique en fameux et
un coup de force là on s'attendait à
quelque chose
du même acabit forcément une nomination
est un gouvernement qu'ils allaient
élargir encore sa majorité et non il
nomme elisabeth bornes dont on dit levée
dès avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle quelle était la favorite
pour matinée il n'y a pas eu de surprise
pas de quoi relancer à terre une
communication c'est très décevant et oui
ça ne crée pas de dynamique ce qui fait
que depuis ce moment là le gouvernement
en plus il sait pas c'est autre chose
c'est que le temps entre la
présidentielle et législatives et en
étayant étaient moins importants que
d'habitude on est entré immédiatement
après la nomination du gouvernement en
période de réserve les nouveaux
ministres n'ont pas pu se présenter la
bonne dynamique habituelle n'a pas
existé et le gouvernement l'âne voilà le
le camp en macro niant s'est retrouvé
immédiatement sur la défensive il n'a
pas agité de nouveaux thèmes de campagne
il est resté sur le sur l'idée de la
reconduction tacite du bail nous avons
bien gouverner donc nous demandons à
faire 50 plus ça suffit on valoir à
mobiliser une partie de son électorat
mais ça ne suffit pas à élargir son
assise et donc salle mais possiblement
en difficulté restons quand même prudent
parce que là on parle du premier tour il
y aura de menton beaucoup de choses vont
se passer pendant l'entre-deux-tours
mais on n'y est pas encore catherine
tricot comment vous vous analysé cette
stratégie des manuels macron de vouloir
temporiser comme ça à tout prix la seule
mesure qui est à imprimer lors de
l'élection présidentielle c'est la
retraite à 65 ans et comme vous venez de
le rappeler parce qu'anne c'est les gens
qui ont plus de 65 ans qui ont donné
leurs votes à jean nohain emmanuel
macron ça veut dire qu'il veut imposer
une mesure qui n'est soutenu finalement
que parce qu'ils ne sont pas concernés
par cette mesure on a vraiment dans le
pays une opposition à cette mesure alors
du coup il a noyé le poisson entre les
deux tours et renault et le poisson un
petit peu du il a reporté à la rentrée
prochaine en
même temps que quand même elle sera
faite en 2023 etc etc c'est à dire que
en fait il ne voulait surtout pas de
débat politique sur cette seule mesure
qui a marqué les esprits si ça devenait
un référendum pour ou contre la la la
retraite à 60 ans et à 65 ans je pense
que le match n'était pas gagné donc il
avait intérêt à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
mobilisation de tous ceux qui ont moins
de 65 ans et qui sont concernés
potentiellement par cette transformation
et qui sont menacés je dirais par cette
transformation donc pas de polémique on
fait profil bas ont fait les thés noirs
et les thés noirs c'est madame bornes
c'est tout le gouvernement dans son
ensemble a quand même pas de surprise
mais elles sont où
rien de
rien de remarquable dedans enfin cesser
ses seins étaient quand même c'est un
été noir face et franchement voilà il
lui même ça c'est votre regard de la
revue regards oui c'est mon regard mais
je dirais je pense qu'il y avait il ya
pas de personnalité truculente qui qui
porte un discours parce que m la réserve
c'est sur des annonces c'est pas sur le
droit de parler ils pouvaient parler ils
n'ont pas parlé parce qu'ils n'ont rien
à dire et que my dad besoin pour
consigne de ne pas prendre le risque
entre guillemets parle apparemment nos
libéraux n'avaient l'art même pas d'être
au courant de ce qu'était le conseil
national de la refondation hier matin
quand tu y étais sur france inter bruno
cautrès ce sur cette disparition du chef
de l'état pendant plusieurs semaines ce
silence du gouvernement le fait aussi
qu'on a un peu mis les thés noirs sur
des réformes importantes qui pouvait
peut-être déplaire à une partie de
l'électorat comment vous analyser ça
c'est comment créer une dynamique de
campagne dans ces conditions d'abord il
faut rappeler que c'est le deuxième
mandat d' emmanuel macron donc c'est
toujours beaucoup plus compliqué de
créer une dynamique à l'issue d'une
réélection que il ya cinq ans quand le
jeune président de 39 ans surprend
les français et par une sorte d'exploit
personnel d'être élus présents de
république à la première élection à
laquelle il s'est jamais présenté à
l'âge de 39 ans donc là on est dans tout
autre contexte cinq ans à cinq ans après
il n'a pas misé au fond sur l'effet de
surprise de la nomination d'un premier
ministre d'une première ministre qui
jouerait de ce point de vue l effet de
surprise comme mitterrand 88 avec la
domine sans de michel rocard qui quand
damas mansle une personnalité déjà assez
emblématique très connu et qui incarne
un peu une autre manière de une autre
direction politique que celle de 1981
donc il n'a pas misé il n'a pas misé là
dessus j'ai cru un moment donné et je
reste de ceux prévus là avec quelques
points d'interrogation j'ai créé un
moment donné que tout de suite emmanuel
macron voudrait renouer avec le coeur du
maquereau nisme de départ alors quand on
voit le premier déplacement de la
première ministre qui va auprès
d'associations qui luttent pour
l'insertion professionnelle sociale de
deux femmes issues de l'immigration
lorsque l'on voit la référence au
conseil national de la refondation la
nomination de pap ndiaye oms l'iba
finalement on essaye de renouer avec la
le l'histoire le logiciel du début c'est
à dire au fond une société française qui
misent sur au fond l'émancipation qui
mise sur la seconde chance mais tout ça
pour le moment n'est pas explicitée il
faut aller le chercher nous analystes il
faut aller le chercher dans différents
éléments ça n'est pas posée sur la table
ce n'est pas explicite et quand on relit
l'interview du chef de l'état à la
presse quotidienne il mélange les deux
les deux dimensions temporelles le court
terme les urgences l'hôpital etc et puis
le long terme la refondation mais il
aura un moment donné un souci qui lui
aussi va apparaître quand même
rapidement qui aimait si un conseil
national de la refondation et on a quoi
sert le parlement à quoi a servi le
premier grand débat oui je pars en
présence un des garants du grand débat
national
donc ça posera defacto cette question où
est passé le premier grand débat
cette stratégie de nos campagnes ou
d'anésthésie de la campagne n'a pas
protégé emmanuel macron des polémiques
qui a eu celle du stade de france on en
a parlé et puis il ya eu ces accusations
de viol et d'agressions sexuelles contre
damien abad ancien responsable du groupe
l'est républicain à l'assemblée rallier
à emmanuel macron avant de s'intéresser
aux éventuelles conséquences nationales
de cette affaire on s'est rendu sur le
terrain dans sa circonscription où
damien abad est en campagne aujourd'hui
pour essayer d'être réélu pour voir un
peu les effets que cela produit c'est un
reportage de stéphanie des pierres et
pierre yves deheunynck
malgré l'accolade et les signes de
soutien damien abad et moins détendu
qu'à l'habitude quand il sillonne le
marché d'oyonnax le nouveau ministre des
solidarités bataille pour être réélu
député mais sa campagne est entachée par
deux accusations de viol pour des faits
remontant à 2010 et 2011 le ministre a
clamé son innocence il refuse désormais
de s'exprimer sur le sujet j'ai pas de
commentaires à faire là-dessus j'ai déjà
apporté des réponses c'est plus
compliqué de faire campagne absolument
pas vous savez les gens me connaissent
savent qui je suis donc fait la même
campagne que j'ai fait il ya cinq ans
que j'ai fait il ya dix ans que j'ai
fait sur un an pour le département ici
tout le monde a eu vent de la faire et
elle suscite une certaine gêne chez les
habitants il y a ceux qui doutent et ce
qu'ils lui renouvellent leur confiance
moi je crois pas du tout à ces calomnies
déjà au concret temps compte tenu de son
handicap c'est impossible moi je
compense corps à corps ouais je pense à
mon point de vue c'est plutôt politique
on est un peu étonné quand même que ça
éclate maintenant mpa épave j'aime bien
quand même pas le fait de dire tout ce
qu'il a fait pour la population pour les
personnes qui l'a beaucoup aidée mais
c'est vrai que ça influencera quand même
le vote c'est donc vous ne voterez pas
pour lui je ne pense pas le député
sortant doit aussi expliqué pourquoi il
a quitté les républicains pour entrer au
gouvernement
très implanté il fait le pari que les
électeurs comprendre le sujet pour moi
aujourd'hui de gagner cette élection
législative c'est de montrer à mes
habitant nasir construction que je peux
changer un certain nombre de choses et
engager des réformes pour le bien et la
belgique cette nomination comme ministre
c'est l'angle d'attaqué de ses
concurrents qui ne parle pas de la faire
pour les républicains il n'était pas
question de laisser le champ libre à
leur ancien président de groupe à
l'assemblée désormais ministre
d'emmanuel macron lr a donc trouvé un
autre candidat in extremis julien
martinez un élu municipal à oyonnax
voulait aussi défendre les valeurs de ma
famille politique
suite à la suite au retournement de
veste de monsieur abad et donc c'était
important pour moi à la fois défendre
mon territoire et défendre les valeurs
ma famille politique bonjour je me
permets de me présenter je suis
candidate pour devenir notre
représentante à l'assemblée ont lieu
place de monsieur abad
s'il ya une candidate qui espère tirer
profit du ralliement du député sortant
la majorité présidentielle c'est bien
l'insoumise florence pisani ça clarifie
vraiment les enjeux par rapport aux
électeurs de la circonscription
ils savent que s'ils votent pour
monsieur abad il va voter pour les
projets de monsieur bacrot du coup c'est
plus facile d'expliquer aux gens que non
seulement on porte ce programme on
pourra appliquer si on a une majorité
mais que dans tous les cas le choix
qu'ils font c'est pour le programme de
monsieur maquereau ou compte le
programme
après l'autre concurrente sérieuse de
damien abad c'est elle joël nambotin la
candidate du rassemblement national elle
essaye de faire fructifier le très bon
score de marine le pen 49 2% au second
tour de la présidentielle
sur la circonscription à part les villes
les grandes villes toute la ruralité à
voter rassemblement national
donc j'ai chassé là-dessus qu'il faut
jouer sur la ruralité l'éloignement
cette militante de longue date du r'n
fera-t-elle vaciller le député sortant
au total il y a dix candidat dans cette
circonscription
damien abad joue gros comme les autres
ministres candidats s'il perd aux
législatives il devra quitter le
gouvernement c'est la règle définie par
emmanuel macron étienne girard ce qui
ressort de ce reportage est ce que
localement visiblement cette affaire
abah n'en est pas vraiment une en tout
cas pour les électeurs de cette
circonscription ça vous surprend non ça
me surprend pas parce qu'on l'avait déjà
vu à tourcoing au tour de gérald
darmanin c'est à dire que des hommes
politiques qui sont bien implantés sont
finalement peu affecté par des affaires
qui touchent leur exemplarité des
affaires qui peuvent être de violence
d'accusations de violences sexistes et
sexuelles quand il n'ya pas de deux
condamnations ici c'est un peu le cas il
faut voir que dans la circonscription de
damien abad on n'est pas dans une
circonscription on n'est pas en
seine-saint-denis ni dans l'aisne on
n'est pas dans des circonscriptions où
marine le pen ou jean luc mélenchon font
des scores extrêmement haut c'est
emmanuel macron qui est arrivé en tête
et donc il ya une certaine continuité à
ce que ce soit le candidat de la
majorité qui apparaissent comme le
favori d'autant que damien abad
semble-t-il mais on verra dimanche est
bien implantée dans sa fille on attend
de voir le résultat du scrutin au
premier tour ça c'est la vision au
niveau local des conséquences des
affaires et puis il ya les concerne les
conséquences au niveau national et là on
a ce sondage de l'institut au doxa qui a
donc posé la question dans
les colonnes du figaro on le voit
apparaître voilà cet événement contre at
il dans votre vote réponse pour le stade
de france oui à 33% pour la faire à badr
oui à 30 2% et pour la passagère tué à
paris par des policiers après un refus
d'obtempérer oui à 29% pascal perrineau
c'est quand même très élevé ce taux de
personnes qui disent que leur vote va
peut-être évoluer région cela pourquoi
parce que beaucoup d'électeurs
maintenant qu'il soit de gauche de
droite ou d'ailleurs ont perdu leur
système de repères traditionnels pour
reconstruire leur choix et donc le vote
conjoncturel c'est à dire en fonction
d'événements de la conjoncture et est un
vote qui peut être important et en effet
quand un tiers de la population vous dis
que ce qui s'est passé au stade de
france est important dans son vote ça
montre que le poids de la conjoncture et
les effets donc de même deux derniers
moments
sur le vote
cependant faut faire attention une fois
on a assez donné ça jouera d'accord dans
votre vote mais de quelle manière et ça
oui de quelle manière sûre il ya des
gens qui considèrent certainement que
certes c'est pitoyable ce qui s'est
passé au stade de france mais que ça a
été surévaluée d'autres diront c'est
comme marine le pen tout à fait
révélateur
du fait qu'il n'ya pas assez de forces
de l'ordre qui lie à un laxisme et que
la voyoucratie et sur certains
territoires devenus la puissance
dominante donc il faut faire très très
attention qu'est-ce qu'on tire du fait
que l'on dit oui ça va compter dans mon
vote comment dans quel sens ça c'est une
autre question se sont quand même trois
affaires qui sont très préjudiciables
pour le gouvernement alors je vais vous
poser la question la troisième affaire
et peut peut-être porter préjudice à
jean luc mélenchon
la police tu cette phrase c'est alors la
swim effet c'est pas ça qui c'est pas ça
qui était interrogé alors
le fait que cette jeune femme soit morte
alors que elle était passagère d'un
véhicule qui et c'est donc on n'a pas
interrogé sur est-ce que la phrase de
jean luc mélenchon va compter dans votre
bâton interrogé sur cet événement et les
trois événements mis bout-à-bout quand
même 1 10 un
problème notamment de relation avec la
question de la légalité de la loi de la
moralité de l'ordre du sens des choses
là on se dit qu'on a un pour un
président qui se voulait exemplaire tout
ça n'est pas absolument exemplaire et
qu'il ya une question qui commence à
interroger profondément le pays sur à
qui s'applique la loi comment elles
s'appliquent que fait la police ça
devient une question qui à mon avis est
demandé est ce que je voudrais juste
rajouter un tout petit peu c'est que je
en ne faisant pas dans ne faisant pas
campagne emmanuel macron c est aussi
exposée à ce que des événements d'un
secours emplissent tout l'espace c'est à
dire que il s'est exposé aux faits
divers la et les trois faits divers en
l'occurrence lui sont préjudiciables à
mon avis j'ai une dernière question à
poser à bruno cautrès avant de passer à
la stratégie de campagne de jean luc
mélenchon on a vu ces derniers jours au
delà des manuels macron les principaux
ténors de la majorité monter au front
pour essayer de diaboliser jean luc
mélenchon bruno le maire qui le
rebaptise le chavez gaulois christophe
castaner qui déclare que la nuque baisse
s'est tous les clichés du monde
soviétique
ça peut marcher de jouer sur les peurs
comme ça et si oui auprès de quel
électorat c'est toujours très compliqué
de mesurer comment ça peut ce genre de
communication peut peut marcher en même
temps que ça renvoie et me jean luc
mélenchon à
facettes de son image qui sont les plus
on va dire les plus contestés dans
pendant dans le piémont mais en même
temps dans son camp au contraire ça
l'install comme le personnage qui fait
peur emmanuel macron la preuve c'est
qu'on est obligé de charger la barque on
obligé de forcer le trait c'est un signe
de fébrilité et donc dans son camp au
contraire ça peut être interprété comme
le fait que décidément il est vraiment
l'insoumis c'est ce qu'a dit jean luc
mélenchon panique à bord quand il a vu
les manuels
lui-même lui-même on joue on voit on
voit qu'il est fidèle à son code
vestimentaire de la soumis en campagne
il revient sur les thèmes qui sont ses
thèmes de prédilection et donc c'est
difficile parce que les effets vont être
un peu paradoxaux dans les différents
dans les différents électorats mais à
l'intérieur de son électorat ça s'ils
mentent au contraire l'image du duduk du
patron de l'opposition du futur patron
de l'opposition la preuve c'est que
tout le monde tire sur lui dans la dans
la majorité et donc ça concentre les
regards sur sur lui avec des effets sans
doute un peu voilà des dépendants des
différends électoraux alors on va
s'intéresser donc à la stratégie de jean
luc mélenchon on a le sentiment
rétrospectivement qu'il l'avait exposé
dès la mi janvier lors de ce meeting de
campagne présidentielle on va redorer
écouter l'extrait de son discours fait
confiance à une tortue électorale
s'agace comme moi
rien ne sert de courir
il faut partir à point et j'ai déjà
épuisé quelques lièvres
catherine tricot lelièvre macron s'est
réveillé un peu tard on en a parlé la
tortue s'agace baisse cédant c'est très
très tôt vous connaissez bien jean-luc
mélenchon la france est soumise est ce
que c'est une stratégie qui a été pensé
dès le mois de janvier ou non sens je ne
crois pas du tout je pensais que le
résultat de jean luc mélenchon plus le
résultat des autres n'était pas écrit
d'avancé
dire que le fait qu'il fasse 22% et que
tous les autres fassent moins de 5 voir
le résultat de la nidal god qui a été
rappelé tout à l'heure un 78 ans n'était
pas absolument écrit dans le marbre je
pense qu'il y avait l'idée qu'il fallait
une union des gauches à s'est exprimée
très tôt notamment on se souvient de
cette primaire populaire qui avait quand
même suscité 400000 la mobilisation de
400 mille citoyens avec des moyens de
bric et de broc qui ont dit il faut une
union est en fait jean luc mélenchon il
date jamais cru à cette alliance de la
gauche à froid c'est à dire sur la base
d'un accord mais là il a battu tout le
monde et il a imposé il a tordu le bras
à tout le monde pour dire maintenant et
pourquoi il l'a fait parce que c'est lui
qui d'une part prend le lead de manière
incontesté deuxièmement il sait qu'en
2017 il n'a pas proposé de perspectives
et du coup il sort avec seulement un
groupe de 17 députés série sort
finalement pas très forts de la campagne
des présidentielles et qui va mettre
vraiment mon temps à s'en remettre c'est
à dire que le fait qu'il fasse la gueule
et qui ne propose pas de perspective en
2017 2018 2019 ça va durer un petit
moment qu'ils se elle a tiré les leçons
je pense qu'il aille à ce moment là il
se met dans une position en 2017 il est
en rupture c'est la ligne populiste qui
triomphe là il ne pas pu de gauche et il
renie absolument toutes les autres
partis de gauche et très idiot commises
notamment le néant et là je sais pas
quoi la mort et le néant et il veut plus
absolument pas adressé la parole aux
socialistes etc etc et ça c'est le début
et finalement il se rend compte que ça
l'amène dans une limite et là il va
saisir il va avoir l'intelligence de
saisir ce moment historique où il fait
22 % ce qui n'est quand même
depuis jacques duclos 1969 où il fait 21
% le parti communiste candidat du parti
commises en 69 et 21% ça ne s'était
jamais vu un candidat de la gauche de
gauche passant la barre des 20 ça ne
s'était jamais vu en france là il le
fait et il le fait en éliminant d une
donc il leur tend le bras et il leur
donne en même temps il leur tend le bras
et en même temps il leur donne une
chance d'exister c'est ça qui rend
possible autre secteur permet de je vais
vous donne à cordes je vais vous donner
un groupe et ce qui n'était pas acquis
sans cet accord étienne girard on vient
de voir déjà ce qu'a réussi jean luc
mélenchon à cette nuit baisse à laquelle
peu de gens croyaient jusqu'où peut
grimper la tortue saga c'est ce qu'on
peut raisonnablement envisager une
cohabitation ou ça vous paraît
totalement inimaginable ça me paraît
plus si inimaginable
vous m'auriez interrogé il ya un mois je
vous aurais dit c'est inimaginable
je ne dis plus parce que je regarde les
enquêtes d'opinion et que valent ces
enquêtes d'opinion des voix au premier
tour alors les instituts de sondage ont
l'air de dire c'est quand même l'un des
scrutins les plus compliqué pour eux il
ya 577 élections en fait oui oui alors
c'est pour ça qu'il faut rester très
prudent et je ne crois pas que les
projections en terme de sièges sont
absolument
qu'on peut s'y fier scientifiquement je
m'étais fait une comparaison avec 1997
une semaine avant le scrutin des
législatives
la droite était donnée gagnante en
termes de sièges par avec une avance de
39 à 135 sièges selon les instituts de
sondage la gauche a gagné avec une
avance de 60 si fier en revanche les
délais les sondages en termes de voix
eux avaient bien saisi ce qui s'était
passé dans le pays donc qu'ils aient une
un souffle une dynamique nuque dimanche
je crois qu'on la verra alors est ce que
en termes de sièges on le verra au soir
du second tour ça dépendra beaucoup de
ce qui va se passer entre les deux tours
en termes de discours de
repositionnement politique de choix
stratégiques et politiques j'ai un vrai
doute sur la dernière semaine de
mélenchon et cette formule la police tue
vous pensez qu'il ya sur le tranchant
oui ça montre que il propose une vision
de la société ça rend tangible
l'alternative est la différence de
vision de la société qu'il a avec
emmanuel macron messar mobilis est
susceptible de remobiliser un des gens
qui sont absolument opposé à sa vision
de la société qui sont attachés à
l'ordre tout simplement j'aimerais vous
entendre vous pascal perrineau sur autre
chose sur cette formule élisez moi
premier ministre de jean luc mélenchon
est ce que vous diriez que c'est un coup
de génie ou pas
c'est une grande habileté ça recouvre
une fois de plus mais comme souvent
communication quelque chose d'absurde
puisque le premier ministre népalais pas
élu dans la constitution quand on est
attaché à la loi constitutionnelle en
effet c'est et c'est un pouvoir propre
du président c'est le président qui
choisit il l'a rappelé emmanuel macron
la première minute ben oui parce que
c'est dans notre texte fondamental que
nous respectons tous du moins je
l'espère en revanche on sait très bien
que s'il ya une majorité législative
opposés au président on rentre
objectivement dans une situation qui est
une situation de cohabitation et que la
marge de manoeuvre à ce moment-là du
président pour choisir son premier
ministre n'est pas tout à fait nul on
l'avait vu avec mitterrand lors de la
première cohabitation il y avait certes
un premier ministre qu'on lui proposait
à droite qu'il refusait et puis voilà
donc il aura il sera obligé de nommer le
chef de la majorité qui auraient
éventuellement gagner un le chef de
l'annuel ps mais vous y croyez vous à la
perspective d'une cohabitation jaune en
moi personnellement je n'y crois pas
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord on parle
d'une union de la gauche mais est ce que
c'est une union de la gauche du ps sai
l'union de la gauche c'est très précis
ça existait l'union de la gauche dans
les années 70 c'est basket survivre à la
gouache plurielle non non non c'est pas
ça l'union de la gauche c'était une
union qui rassemblait toutes les forces
politiques jusqu'au parti communiste et
jamais au delà là on a dépassé le parti
communiste et voilà cette union de la
gauche avec la gauche de la gauche et
même l'extrême gauche puisque le pays et
le npa ont tardé pendant aux
négociations et voilà donc c'est une
union de la gauche tout à fait
particulière
d'autre part une union de la gauche mais
ça préserve au premier tour la pluralité
des familles lorsqu'il y avait une union
de la gauche ou la gauche plurielle il y
avait un candidat socialiste il y avait
un candidat communiste et l'union se
faisait entre les deux tours là c'est
l'union avant le second tour dans des
conditions tout à fait particulière
parce que qui a la part la plus énorme
du gâteau qui a imposé sa loi là c'est
la france a soumises et la france
insoumise a soumis en effet un parti
socialiste en difficulté un parti
communiste en difficulté et des verts en
difficulté mais c'est la loi de la
france a soumises qui s'est imposé donc
c'est une union de la gauche voyait il
ya on se méprend sur les termes ça n'a
rien à voir avec l'union de la gauche
telle qu'elle se pratique depuis 1936 et
le front populaire ça n'a rien à voir
c'est autre chose dont il s'agit
j'aimerais qu'on se penche aussi sur
l'un des enjeux sur le terrain dans
certaines circonscriptions de cette
campagne des législatives et qui permet
à la france insoumise et à la nuque de
mobiliser son électorat c'est la
présence de ministres deux ministres
candidats c'est le cas notamment de
clément bonne dans la 7e circonscription
de paris c'est un reportage de emma
quand tu es clé à jouer avec les os eu
un ministre sous pression clément bonne
chargé de l'europe joue gros sa place au
sein du gouvernement pour sa première
campagne il a choisi la difficulté avec
une circonscription ancré à gauche
tu avais peur de l'inquiétude si je puis
dire je serais pas allé dans une
campagne électorale dans une
circonscription où je sais que c'est
difficile parce que c'est une
circonscription de gauche depuis
longtemps élections par définition c'est
la boîte est la démocratie du suffrage
universel ce test arisk pour chacune et
chacun pour moi l'a compris je pas le
seul conscient du danger qui l'attend il
compte bien ratissé large si des
électeurs qui ont voté à droite au
premier tour mais faisons les choses
dans l'ordre se valent me soutenir
contre un populisme et l'extrême gauche
très bien mais je parlerai aussi à des
électeurs qui peut-être ont été tentées
venant de la gauche même un moment par
le ps et qui je crois ferait fausse
route à mon sens vous leur parlez aussi
je prends leur à tout le monde le danger
face à lui c'est elle
caroline mécary le visage de la nuque
cette avocate spécialisée dans la
défense des droits lgbt arrive en tête
selon un sondage ifop fiducial
41% des intentions de vote contre 36
pour clément bonne j'ai en face de moi
un ministre candidat ou un candidat
ministre donc lorsqu'il intervient dans
les médias on sait jamais s'il
intervient comme candidat ou comme
ministre donc il a une surface
médiatique que je n'ai pas et ensuite
que lui soit sous pression jarry vous
dire c'est son problème moi ça me
regarde pas et j'aime ça ne m'intéresse
pas dans la circonscription je pense
qu'on peut gagner si on est très très
très mobilisé et on peut l'arraché cette
circonscription la nouvelle alliance de
la gauche convaincu de pouvoir renverser
la table si ces électeurs sont au rendez
vous
là en fait les gens ont compris
qu'institutionnellement l'avait la
possibilité de gagner la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale et donc de pouvoir
appliquer notre programme est d'empêcher
le président macro d'appliquer le sien
qui est un programme de la droite
néolibérale pour arbitrer ce duel cet
homme aurélien véron élus les
républicains au conseil de paris lui a
déjà choisi son camp au second tour
éventuellement si je ne fuis pas mais je
fais tout pour y être ni le pen linux
pour moi c'est là la nuque c'est le pen
y sont deux mots que je combats pour
l'action de valeur et
oui de valeurs profondes donc ça sera
pas nul mais en tout cas voici les
autres candidats qui se présentent dans
la 7e circonscription de paris bruno
cautrès clément boon n'est pas le seul
ministre ministre dans ce cas de figure
à se présenter dans une circonscription
qui historiquement était plutôt à gauche
comment vous voyez les choses est ce que
ça peut motiver l'électorat de la nuque
de se dire que la ans ils ont la
possibilité de faire tomber un ministre
parce que tout ministre battu aux
législatives sortira du gouvernement oui
sans exagérer le rôle que ça peut avoir
ça ça peut avoir évidemment un rôle
notamment s'il s'agit de figure un peu
emblématique de la macro ni
notamment l'une des dimensions on
parlait de qu'est ce qui va se passer
entre les deux tours une dimension
importante va être dimanche soir que
va-t-il se passer si jamais on voit
beaucoup de candidats de la nuque
qualifier au deuxième tour est en même
temps un certain nombre de ministres
potentiellement en difficulté et ce avec
la combinaison des deux ça peut faire un
effet de mobilisation à gauche alors à
passer à la campagne du rassemblement
national si vous voulez bien une
campagne qui était assez surprenante
marine le pen était sorti de cette
présidentielle très clairement en
première opposante à emmanuel macron
elle a ensuite un peu disparu des radars
l'eau rappel en images il est signé
marion becker
immédiatement après sa défaite à la
présidentielle elle s'est éclipsée
quinze jours de vacances quinze jours de
silence médiatique exploité par jean luc
mélenchon pour lui ravir la place de
première opposante
mais pour son retour au jt de tf1 marine
le pen ne semble pas viser la victoire
je pense que la logique des institutions
veut que le président de la république
et une majorité tout ce qu'ils racontent
autre chose raconte des fables moi je
suis la candidate de la vérité je dis la
vérité aux français en revanche la vraie
question c'est quelle opposition
pour pouvoir combattre la politique d'
emmanuel macron mais depuis tandis que
jean-luc mélenchon mène une campagne
nationale
un marine le pen et joue la carte locale
en écumant méthodiquement les marchés
des circonscriptions du nord qui ont le
plus voté rassemblement national une
campagne de terrain pour soutenir ses
candidats qui ont le plus de chances de
l'emporter avec une rengaine pour lutter
contre l'abstention alors moi je viens
dire aux français aussi si vous votez le
rassemblement national peut arriver en
tête de cette élection législative ça
aussi c'est une réalité tangible mais il
faut voter souvenez-vous de ce qui s'est
passé aux élections régionales nos
élections régionales beaucoup des
millions de français étaient d'accord
avec notre projet mais une partie
d'entre eux n'est pas allé voter et donc
les deux régions que nous pouvions
gagner nous les avons perdu parce que
s'ils ont encore une fois le peuple ne
vote pas le peuple père et fils vote le
peuple gagne pour quels objectifs
un marine le pen n'a cessé de varier ce
week end à hénin beaumont elle appelait
les électeurs à lui donner 100 à 150
députés quand il y a quelques semaines
elle ne visait qu'un groupe
parlementaire puis 60 député
étienne girard on voit bien dans ce
sujet un marine le pen a complètement
changé son fusil d'épaulé après un début
de campagne assez étonnant comment vous
jugez cela oui j'ai trouvé ça
extrêmement étonnant j'ai même trouvé ça
a raté son début de campagne marine le
pen ce fait 41 % des voix l'élection
présidentielle et elle dépose les armes
dès le lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle elle considère que ce
troisième tour n'existent pas en réalité
et donc elle tire un trait immédiatement
sur la victoire à partir du moment où on
expliquait que la logique c'était
clients annuels malraux gaye on ne peut
plus gagner les élections législatives
alors on peut essayer de comprendre
pourquoi elle a fait ça et marie le pen
depuis des années essaye de s'inscrire
dans une filiation gaullienne essaye
d'expliquer qu'elle n'est pas le diable
qu'elle n'est pas dangereuse donc en
expliquant que la logique des
institutions
c'est emmanuel macron qui a une majorité
elle elle dit à l'électorat vous voyez
je connais les codes de la vème
république
je ne suis pas quelqu'un de dangereux
donc vous pourrez me faire confiance
ultérieurement dans le futur mais quand
même à court terme
énormément de députés elle avait le
choix l'aurait pu adopter une autre
stratégie selon 20 pas vraiment je
trouve quand même une forme de
rationalité au fond dans son
comportement
puisque si on ne peut pas gagner une
élection elle sait qu'elle ne peut pas
la gagner autant se ménager préparer la
suite pour dans cinq ans plutôt que
d'avoir fixé un objectif très haut une
barre inatteignable et finalement que
son leadership ou que la conclusion de
son leadership ou rassemblement national
soit un peu fragilisé au fond comment
créer une dynamique de campagne soit
dans cette séquence elle se qualifie
pour la seconde fois au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle elle améliore
beaucoup son score eric zemmour ne l'a
pas tué le rassemblement national aura
potentiellement un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale c'est un bilan qui est assez
honorable finalement si elle avait
l'intention de passer la main et de
confier les rênes jordan bardella donc
finalement voilà il ya une forme de
rationalité peut-être mais c'est vrai
que pour ses troupes pour les adhérents
pour les sympathisants pour les
militants qui aiment faire campagne
c'est un message qui est un peu
déroutant pascal perrineau quand vous
analysez les choses
écoutez non moi je perds je continue à
percevoir sa comme étant d'abord une
candidate qui sort épuisé elle a eu
besoin de les sortir véritablement
épuisé du combat du du second tour et
les vacances sont des vacances trop
longues faut faire attention quand on
fait de la politique 15 jours 15 jours
de vacances quinze jours c'est vraiment
trop surtout entre deux entre deux
élections d'autre part il ya une
relative déception parce que au soir du
premier tour étant donnée son niveau le
fait qu'elle était très nettement devant
par exemple jean luc mélenchon elle
n'était pas écraser du tout par le
président de la république les premiers
sondages montrent qu'elle est plutôt
d'ailleurs aux alentours
45 46 et certains se mettent à croire
que que tout est possible qu'elle peut
gagner et là elle a rétrogradé et même
si c'est beaucoup moins fort qu'en 2017
le débat lui a coûté cher c'est à dire
que le débat a contribué à la
dégradation d'intentions de vote et elle
a été ramenée au fond d'un niveau de 45%
à 1 niveau 2 41 42 % à ce qui ce qui en
effet est extrêmement confortable
beaucoup sans s'en contenteraient mais
il ya une déception il ya une déception
parce que une partie d'elle-même croyait
que l'heure était venue 1 et voilà il
faut après il ya l'accueil du deuil de
ses deux aînés mais ces attentes ce que
vous dites est en fait rejoint ce que je
voudrais c'est juste avant c'est là
qu'en fait il faut pas donner un
objectif inatteignable c'est en effet là
ça a été des ses petits fils ne venons
pas atteint leur objectif et du coup ils
marquent le coup et si on commence à
raconter qu'on va voir 150 députés qu'on
en a 15 ben ça apparaît comme un échec
moi je trouve que avoir un discours de
vérité ce qu'elle a souvent alors il ne
panel n'a souvent un discours assez brut
quoi elle dit les choses si vous votez
pas pour moi ben voilà on n'a pas gagné
les régionales et san et ça nous a pesé
pour la présidentielle objectivement le
fait qu'elle ait raté les régionales
c'était difficile pour nous reste peu de
temps pour parler de la droite j'ai
quand même une dernière question à vous
poser à vous et yann gérard parce que
vous connaissez bien eric zemmour lui
avait consacré un livre est ce que les
candidatures reconquête le parti d'eric
zemmour peuvent coûter des sièges à
l'assemblée au rassemblement national je
ne pense pas parce que dans un qui a un
seul cas de figure dans lequel ils
coûteraient des sièges à marine le pen
au rassemblement national c'est des cas
de figure dans lesquelles le
rassemblement sial serait qualifié pour
le second tour seulement avec les voix
de reconquête donc ce cas de figure ça
veut dire que le rassemblement social
n'est pas très haut dans cette
circonscription est donc ça veut dire
que dans ces circonscriptions là le
rassemblement social ne l'emporterait
pas dans le sud de la france n'a pas
quelques cas de figure qui peuvent se
quelques questions qui peuvent se poser
non alors il y aura la circonscription
d'eric zemmour ou là il peut
effectivement c'est ce que semblent dire
les sondages il est au coude à coude
avec son rival du rassemble nationale et
là il peut damer le pion et ce siège au
rassemblent anciens dans les autres
endroits incroyables je ne crois pas et
d'accord en réalité ces salles calcul le
café leur assemblée nationale c'est de
toute façon on a bien besoin d'eux si on
a besoin d'eux on ne gagnera pas donc on
essaye de les sortir de la carte voilà à
ces élections il nous reste trois
minutes pour évoquer la campagne des
républicains à présent christian jacob a
eu cette phrase on créera la surprise
parce que nous sommes capables de
représenter les territoires bruno
cautrès on a un peu le sentiment que
cette campagne elle a été avant tout
nationale est-ce que c'est pertinent de
miser sur l'ancrage local des élus
sortants les républicains qui sont assez
nombreux dans une phase aussi difficile
que la leur aujourd'hui oui c'est même
c'est encore une fois là c'est encore
assez rationnel de miser sur l'ancrage
pour essayer de sauver les meubles ça va
compter dans le vote des français
l'ancrage local non mais en tout cas le
fait de rencontrer dans l'offre
électorale dans son bureau de vote une
personnalité dont on connaît le nom ou
qu'on a eu l'occasion d'apprécier c'est
peut-être un avantage pour un avantage
pour eux c'est vrai que la dimension
proprement nationale elle est presque
une impossibilité là pour les
républicains ils sortent en lambeaux de
cette élection présidentielle vu le
score de leurs de leur candidate il ya
des questions stratégiques fondamentales
qui vont se poser pour eux en début
d'émission je disais que la campagne
était potentiellement prometteuse qui
sait il faudra voir si la déception est
moins forte qu'attendu pour les
républicains majoritaires et non qu'ils
retrouvent 60 70 sièges je ne sais pas
deux députés hypothèses très optimistes
mais imaginons que on est peut-être
besoin d'eux voilà qu'est ce que j'avais
posé avoue pascal perrineau il y en a au
sein de la droite qui se voit un peu en
faisant de roi d'une future assemblée
sans majorité absolue et donc les
républicains pourraient être moins
nombreuses mais offrir la majorité à
emmanuel martinez peut être si emmanuel
macron dispose d'une majorité relative
tout dépendra combien de députés lui
manquent pour atteindre la fameuse barre
des 2 189 c'est à dire la majorité
absolue des députés six et huit à dix
députés il y aura pas de problème il
fera ce que michel rocard avait fait en
1988 on ira voir de temps en temps les
élus d'outre-mer tel ou tel élu divers
tel ou tel élu et l'air est en revanche
s'il manque à la majorité ensemble s'il
lui manque 25 sièges ou 30 sièges là
c'est une autre paire de manches et là
il y aura besoin d'un accord plus stable
avec un gros un accord de gouvernement
vous l'envisagez vous parce qu'à droite
pour l'instant on refuse d'entendre ça
mais ça ne serait pas complètement
impossible souvenons-nous michel rocard
avait pratiqué une ouverture en 1988 il
avait ouvert en particulier à des hommes
de droit comme soissons et à des hommes
du centre comme l'ancien maire de metz
jean marie rausch donc un tel type
d'accord n'est pas impossible sachant
d'autre part j'ai regardé très
attentivement dans nos enquêtes du
cevipof les second choix vous savez les
second choix des électeurs qui votent et
l'air ou lui dit cemac rompait et lé
second choix des électeurs macron c'est
souvent elle est rude et le mot de la
fin pour vous 4 entre co vous avez
réservé votre temps de parole moulié
parler de la droite oui parce que ce que
je pensais qu'il ya faire le roi en
cadeau ou maquereau n'aurait pas sa
majorité mais à l'intérieur de la macro
ni ya quand même des différences et via
notamment le parti d'edouard philippe
qui peut trouver un appui du côté de l
air c'est à dire que la suite de
l'histoire le rapport de force à
l'intérieur deux ensembles va aussi
dépendre de possibles alliances avec les
républicains et l'autre chose que je
voulais dire c'est qu'en fait ce que ce
à quoi nous assistons c'est un retour du
clivage gauche droite avec la macro ni
ensemble qui s'ancre ce que vous venez
de dire très bien pascal perrineau c'est
à dire qu'en fait on a un arc qui va de
ensemble est le candidat tout à l'heure
a dit moi ça sera pas la nuque
sous-entendu ça sera macron donc on a
bien une alliance qui est en train de se
faire formellement ou pas on verra
comment ça va se passer mais en tout cas
il ya un axe macro et l'eire qui se
constitue face à la nuque par ailleurs
donc on a le clivage gauche-droite se
reconstitue merci beaucoup c'est la fin
de cette émission merci d'être venus
débattre sur ce plateau c'était
passionnant
ratez pas notre soirée électorale
dimanche soir sperry fidèle au poste sur
lcp dans un instant z zone d'education
documentaire présenté par valérie
brochard avec le documentaire prince les
chimères de l'exil suivie d'un débat
avec les élèves du lycée théodore
aubanel d'avignon il me reste à vous
souhaiter un bon week-end à tous
n'oubliez pas donc on vote dimanche pour
la prochaine assemblée nationale passer
une bonne soirée sur lcp
[Musique]